so we've been looking in this computer
file and the previous one and how when
we press a key on a keyboard what
actually happens to from that key press
being pressed and the physical hardware
to the software say Microsoft Word
displaying that on screen and the
previous episode if you haven't seen I
suggest you click the link here and go
and watch now we saw what happened at
the hardware side of things so we sort
of left our story where the hardware and
we saw how that depending on what the
things these days said I'll get packaged
up into a serial message which is sent
to a specialist port is interrupted the
cpu and now we're looking at the sort of
the software side of things of what the
operating system does to actually make
this work just like there was many
layers in the hardware there's many
layers in the software so the first
place we need to look in a modern
operating system and I should caveat
this by saying I'm going to talk in
general terms each operating system with
us windows linux mac o s-- probably even
CPM for people I'm sure we're going to
talk in general so yes there'll be some
organ systems to do something different
there were some which merged some steps
that was something that expands some
steps fight about it in the comments so
the first thing that there will be from
this side is that the hardware
interrupted there'll be a bit of
software built into the operating system
which actually handles that interrupt
and probably map it to the right bit of
software to handle where the heart what
we should have hardware's generated it
and eventually summing of that will
handle this is a keyboard interrupt
mapped through whatever is the USB the
Bluetooth the direct connection
depending on how it works and says okay
there's been a keyboard interrupt I know
how to handle this sort of thing and I'm
then going to do it so it'll get the
data and it will say okay this key was
pressed let's say the letter A was
pressed or the letter A was released but
you generally will get messages from the
keyboard so the keys been pressed and
this message to say that the keys been
released so that then we'll get received
by the device driver and these generally
don't actually need to be that
complicated you generally find if you
look at the code say in the Linux kernel
it's open source that the keyboard
software for a simple keyboard like on
someone on the Atari ST or the Falcon it
just reads from a memory
it's relatively straightforward of
course if you've got a USB or Bluetooth
keyboard then you've got to implement
the whole USB and bluetooth stacks
things are a lot more complicated but
that's the point of the device driver it
can handle all that abstracts it away
from your program as a user you just say
what keys been pressed okay so we've got
that data we're now in software we know
this key has been pressed what happens
then
well you generally don't have your
software say your word processor talked
directly to that device driver partly
because you'd have to write it for every
single possible different device driver
you might need do you've got a USB
keyboard or a Bluetooth one whatever it
is and so on you get then you get the
point so what actually happens is inside
say a modern operating system there's a
way of handling input devices keyboards
mice buttons on your machine and so on
that will handle these things and so
when the keyboard device driver detects
a key press it sends that message or is
it generally is turned by that point and
event to the relevant input device which
has been created for that particular
keyboard the other advantage of this is
even having multiple keyboards
connecting your computer quite easily
and you can read them separately don't
always have to but you could do that if
you want to do so you'd have some sort
of event queue inside your operating
system that will and remember this is
inside the operating system kernel so
this is not talking about graphical user
interface or anything at this point
we're just talking about getting the
message from the device driver into the
user land where our programs are running
and when the keys pressed it would send
an event down like it would place an
event into that queue saying this key
was pressed this is what the scan code
was you could at that point convert that
to a ski that I probably actually
happened later in the stack probably
happen in user mode there's no reason
for it to be done there but it could be
done inside the kernel and so on unless
you do inside the kernel the less attack
service you got from a security point of
view
you probably timestamp it so you know
when that happened and so and you put
that into the queue and we imagine this
as a boundary in your software between
what we call user mode which is where
our programs are run and kernel mode
which is where the stuff that wants to
talk to the hardware and that
things that keep things in control and
somewhere on there you'll have some sort
of transfer port and their event queue
before the inputs would come from the
device driver which gets the message
from the keyboard and the software pop
it into the event queue and then when
the program over here read from that it
would pull the first one off and get the
message say this key was pressed or this
key was released so we're now after the
kernel we're out of hardware we've gone
through the device driver in the kernel
we've gone through the kernels input
queues and we're now in user mode and
the software can ask what key has been
pressed now if this was a command line
process it would actually probably be
talking to what's called a pseudo tele
tie board a teletype type interface in
something like Linux or UNIX which
literally emulate the alter of teletype
printers and keyboards and so on and the
conversion from scan codes to ASCII
would be handled at that point in the
implementation of the teletype terminal
for a graphical user interface things
tend to have a few more stages in there
so what you'll generally have is some a
program so on something like a Mac for
example your own called Windows Server
and there's equivalent things X for
example on Linux and in Windows which
handles the whole graphical user
interface so that's sitting there
producing the displays and not working
out which windows active and so on and
it will be that point of the software
stack that will get the key presses from
the operating system so that part of it
the Windows Server let's just use it as
a term will get the key presses and then
it will look to say okay I've got this
key press aids been pressed and where do
I actually send this to which window is
receiving this is it the word processor
would running on this or is it going
into the email client or is it going
into a signal to send a secure text
message or wherever it is it's going
where's it got to go
and in those which windows active so it
will then say okay this is going to this
this window is active we need to send
this to this program now how does that
happen well again it's similar to what
happens here every graphical user
interface program generally has at its
heart an event processing message
processing loop and basically the way
they work it's sometimes explicit you
sometimes have to code
so if you program Windows around 20
years ago you would write code which
would have things like peak message
translate message
dispatch message I'm not remembering the
names right functions in a tight loop to
handle all those things if you're
writing code on a acorn archimedes you
would call s y Wimpole and soul to do is
to get the messages and base you can
call that in a loop and then you get a
message and dispatch it these days it
tends to get wrapped up and things so
it's actually hidden in library code and
things but generally it's still doing
the same thing so the window server will
send an event to your program saying a
key has been pressed in this window and
so on it'll happen and again that by
that point we probably convert it so
still got the scan code there but we've
probably also converted it into the
ASCII code or the unicode code as well
that will be handled by the window
server because it can then localize it
and do whatever it's needed knowing what
sort of keyboard you've got connected
and so on there's ways that these can be
automatically configured so you'd
actually have to physically tell it
unless you want to so the windows server
will package but at this point you won't
use the same sort of event format that
the kernel use it could but generally
there's probably a more specific one
which is tied in to which windows and
things are being used that's then got
into your program and you say hey let's
say with Microsoft Word these press the
a key you then need to do in your
program whatever you need to do in your
program to update your data structures
to say that whatever document we had
before we now need to put an A at
wherever the current cursor is in that
and that depends on what how your
program is written if your game and that
you've got WASD for controlling movement
when you press a well then you want to
update where the player or the cameras
position is on the screen at that point
once you're into the user code the user
program that we're interacting with what
happens is up to how the program works
it may be that it does absolutely
nothing because it doesn't respond to
that key that's a simple case at that
point we don't know what's happening is
a black box it's the program but we said
then what happens
at that point we still haven't updated
the screen we've pressed the kini gun
and it may be that there's no visual
effect from pressing that key you could
write a pro and where that didn't happen
and then two hours later it put pops up
a picture of Tom and Jerry on the screen
to surprise you if you pressed the wrong
key probably not going to write a
program like that but you could what's
going to happen well we still need to
redraw the screen so what will happen
inside that say the word presser you
press the a key we've updated the data
structures to say we can now got an A in
our document we will then finally say we
want to redraw the current window that's
representing that document and what
that'll actually probably probably won't
draw it then and there
well it'll probably do is tell the
window server that this this window
needs redrawing and then eventually that
will then come and redraw it and the
reason why that happens is actually the
window main redrawing anyway because
you've moved the screen or whatever it
is you brought that to the front and
actually you can then combine the
redraws and speed things up a little bit
and that's pretty much the story of what
happens when you press a key on a
computer it's quite involved what's
fascinating though is I read an article
that actually measured the latency the
time it takes from you pressing a key on
a keyboard to it appearing or having an
effect on the screen and actually on
modern computer systems whether it's
Windows Mac or Linux it's incredibly
long compared to what it was like on
something like the Apple 2 or the BBC
micro behind me on the Apple 2 or the
BBC micro it effectively did it on the
next frame read or within 30
milliseconds on a modern PC is
significantly longer than that are all
peas treated equally shift control ABC
are they all the same number one keypad
F key so there's very good question are
all keys treated equally the short
answer is yes and the long answer is no
it depends where you get up to so
implementation of the keyboard the shift
keys the caps lock key the num lock key
all handled identically obviously some
of them have LEDs associated with them
to light up when they're press or not
generally the computer will tell the
keyboard to light those LEDs or not like
those LEDs so you press a key and the
computer sends a message back thanks
implemented in the keyboard it depends
on the implementation so at the hardware
level they're probably identical in the
kernel that probably identical I think
you'd probably be when you get to the
point of the Windows Server or the
actual command line teletype terminal
that it would actually be handled and
again if you actually look at the
implementation of the operating systems
you can find out what modifier keys are
pressed you generally don't get events
for those keys
you only get events being passed so that
the keys being pressed but when you get
that event you can say oh ships pressed
as well or ships not pressed and so you
can work out what's going on so the
answer is yes and no that time I was
playing manic miner and I jump and I hit
the key I had jumped it was the computer
that got it wrong right possibly
depends what looking the way it was
implemented in things I'm not going to
comment on your game playing ability
just leaves you had a Commodore 64